all right thanks for coming uh it's the
last day of the workshop and we're happy
to have michael celantano talking about
the estimation here
thank you um
so today i'm going to tell you about
some joint work with my advisor
[Music]
the topic i'm going to talk about is
the same topic that andrea discussed at
the workshop
but i'm going to
tell you a few different things about it
in particular i'm going to try to
present to you
an alternative
technique which
is actually probably a bit more
complicated than the one that he
uh presented but i think is interesting
nonetheless
okay so the
the uh the type of model that i look at
is a high dimensional regression model
so we're going to observe uh we're going
to receive n samples
each comes with an outcome y and p
covariates
in this vector x
and the outcome is generated according
to some
kernel p
that depends upon the
variance of the features uh linearly to
the parameter theta which is the object
of estimation
okay
and we're also going to observe this
side information v0
and v0 may be informative about the
unknown parameter theta
in particular the sort of coordinates of
theta and v
are going to be generated jointly
according to some known prior
distribution
i'll call mu theta d
okay we're going to be interested in the
proportional asymptotic so then e
are going to diverge and their limiting
ratio
okay so there's uh
several algorithms or iterative
algorithms that you could use for
estimating data
a class of algorithms that has come up
several times in this workshop is
approximate message passing which
takes this form so we're going to
keep track of the sequence of iterates b
in n dimensions
and iterates a and
t dimensions
and the amp algorithm is going to be
fixed by a choice of f
and g for each time iterate t
and then the amp algorithm is
as written here where the alphas and the
betas are chosen in a particular way
that
is determined by the model
and the choice of functions
f and g
okay provided that alpha and beta are
chosen in that way we get to call this
an amp
algorithm and after t iterations
we will estimate the unknown parameter
theta
by applying some function g to our
iterates and the side information
okay so that's amp several people have
written
okay so this is a figure that i took
from a
paper by uh rba cause a column a pre
milan and deborah
this is just a concrete example of a
high-dimensional regression model so
this is the sparse
phase retrieval model in which we
observe the absolute value of this
linear measurement of
theta
uh and okay the sparsity parameter will
be denoted by rho which is the
ratio or the fraction of coordinates
which are of theta which are active
and okay uh not all of the lines in this
figure are going to be
important for the top but this black
line is the information theoretic
threshold so if we have sort of fewer
measurements
than active coordinates of theta then
recovery of theta is
impossible
and this
solid red line is
an algorithmic threshold so this is the
threshold for a particular amp algorithm
called bayes amp
uh it's sort of conjectured to be what's
achievable by any polynomial time
algorithm but
in this paper it's just presented as the
threshold for for this algorithm-based
amp
uh and we need substantially more
uh measurements than
this information theoretically required
to
recover
so this is perhaps a good example to
keep in mind what we're going to do is
we're going to sort of establish that
this threshold
is a threshold for a much larger class
of arguments
so here's another algorithm it's
gradient descent
we're going to define some
objective which is
a loss term
and a penalty
i've chosen them separately
and gradient descent which everyone
knows
takes steps down this objective
and i've expanded the form of the
gradient here
and the important thing is that it sort
of looks like a and p in a certain sense
the sense being that it involves two
types of operations first in green
multiplication by our design matrix or
its transpose and in red
application of some function coordinate
wise to
the iterates are some function of the
iterates
okay
so okay so
uh the observation is that many
algorithms
involve only these two operations matrix
multiplication and coordinate wise
non-linearities uh which motivates our
definition of the class of general first
order methods
uh which uh okay the definition is just
that it's an iteration which depends it
only uses these two operations so we get
to choose
four functions which map from
t plus one variables to the real line
and the first order method keeps track
of a sequence of iterates in n
dimensions now called u
uh sequence of iterates in
key dimensions now called v
uh these functions are
uh applied row wise so we have t plus
one vectors each of these is
n-dimensional and we apply f sort of to
each row of the matrix that has those as
vectors as columns
and this is the first order the general
first order method it's not
a and p because this sort of second term
is not necessarily chosen in this
special way which allows us to call the
algorithm an amp algorithm
so and this you know will include for
example the gradient descent iteration
i showed on the previous slide
and after t iterations we estimate theta
using some other function applies to the
sequence of iterates up to that point
okay and our
our result is going to be a lower bound
on
the estimation error of a any general
first order method
in the sort of fixed t and going to
infinity
asymptotics which
corresponds to time that's linear in the
size of your data
so what is the lower bound
well uh the lower bound is going to be
uh of the following form it says that
the the sort of limiting estimation
error at fixed t
is the risk in a particular scalar model
of bayesian estimation and the
particular scalar model is going to be
the following we're going to receive a
single noisy gaussian observation of a
scalar random variable theta
and we're also going to observe some
scalar random variable v
data and v are going to be generated
jointly from the same prior that
generated the coordinates of our in our
high dimensional regression model
there's the lower bound stated in a bit
more uh
completeness
under the fixed t
and going to infinity asymptotics
the asymptotic estimation error is lower
bounded by this
base risk in the scalar model
what is
tau t the noise variance in the scalar
model is determined by
the state evolution of this phase amp
algorithm
now we or what have we established that
the sort of optimal first order method
is in fact this phase a and p
algorithm okay now of course the risk of
bayes and p is
bigger than the phase risk
but what's interesting is that sometimes
it's
strictly bigger than the bayes risk and
in these high dimensional regression
models
we know from
these authors
what the bayes risk is uh
and what the risk of bayes amp is and so
we can identify exactly
okay so that's
those are the results and now for the
rest of the time i'm going to
give you a taste of
the technique that we use in our paper
okay so the way that we're going to
prove this lower bound is we're going to
compare
the regression model to a separate
statistical model
and the separate statistical model is
going to live on a completely different
space
but it's going to be very similar or
similar in
several ways to the high dimensional
regression model
okay and i'm going to walk through
several
aspects of both of these models in the
remainder of the talk so first i'm going
to give you the statistical model
and i'm going to give you a class of
algorithms in each model so i've already
told you about the class of algorithms
for the high dimensional regression
models they're the first order methods
and on the computation tree models i'm
going to give you
algorithms which are message passing
algorithms
i'm going to describe to you the
asymptotic error
of these
uh algorithms okay so the asymptotic
error of the general first order method
is going to be given by some state
evolution
and likewise the asymptotic error of the
message passing algorithm will be given
by some state evolution
okay and in both models we'll also have
a description of the base risk
our two storylines they run sort of uh
in parallel okay so two stories
and you know of course these two models
are going to be related so the models
are going to be in bijection with each
other so each high dimensional
regression model is going to be in
bijection with some
computation tree model
and each first order method in the high
dimensional regression model is going to
map naturally to a particular message
passing algorithm
on the corresponding
computation tree model
and the important
thing is going to be that under this
mapping the asymptotic error achieved by
the first order method is going to be
the same asymptotic error achieved by
the
message now uh
you know
this asymptotic error is greater than
the bayes risk in the regression model
uh and likewise on the computation tree
but this sort of correspondence between
the two worlds doesn't actually extend
to the bayes risk so the base risk might
be different in the two worlds
so what i get is okay i get this
inequality trivially
but now i can bound this sort of
algorithmic error
in the regression model using this sort
of string of
equalities and inequalities
i get that the
algorithmic lower bound or the lower
bound on the first order methods in the
regression model
is greater than the
phase error
on the computation tree
and the bayes error on the computation
tree might actually be larger than the
bayes error in the regression model and
so i've established a gap
so this is okay i mean actually i could
just end my talk here i think this is
the main idea
so now i'm just gonna go through this in
a bit more detail
so high dimensional regression so i've
already told you this this is my model
step one
okay so this is just a repetition of an
earlier slide
uh i should tell you a little bit about
more than i've already told you about
the class of algorithms in the
regression model so
the main observation which is not
actually that uh difficult of an
observation to make
is that uh after a sort of change of
variables the any first order method can
be reduced to an amp algorithm okay so
if you give me a first order method
which is defined by these functions
and some
g star
then okay there's some a and p algorithm
meaning there's some choice of f and g
so that the iterates of the amp
algorithm a and b
are related to the iterates of their
first-order methods through some simple
uh
change of variables okay
so that i can sort of
design an ap amp algorithm with f g and
g star so that this theta hat
is exactly the same as the theta hat
that is given to me by the first order
method and that's there's no there's no
asymptotics there that's just uh
an exact equality
okay so i'm i'm only going to consider
amp algorithms on the
regression model without loss of
generality
okay and this is uh state evolution
which i think several of you are
familiar with the state evolution tells
us that the iterates of the amp
algorithm look like gaussian
observations of the unknown parameter
theta
applied to studying the l2 estimation
error that statement tells us the
following
that the amp error which i've written
here and i've expanded here
looks like uh this object asymptotically
so now i replace the sort of amp
iterates with some gaussian
observation of an unknown scalar
quantity
this is the sort of
asymptotic error of some estimator that
received gaussian observations in the
scalar model
and
in order for me to sort of fully specify
to you what this statement means i need
to
tell you well two things i need to tell
you what these coefficients alpha are
and i need to tell you
what the covariance of this gaussian
noise is and that's i mean that is what
state evolution is so i won't write it
but
this is fully explicit
okay
great
uh so
summarizes what i just said we get uh
our high dimensional regression model
and some specification of the functions
that are used by amp there's some
function called state evolution that
maps that to some scalar model that
gives us for example the limiting l2
estimation error
okay and the bayes risk is something
that we know it was established
for linear models by reeves and fister
and then
generalized linear models this larger
class of high-dimensional regression
models by rba and at all
that's i've
given you what i promised which is the
four steps of my story about the high
dimensional regression model
now i'm going to give you the same four
steps for the computation tree
okay so i haven't even told you what the
computation tree model is yet
so the computation tree model lives on
an infinite tree
there's two types of nodes there's
variable nodes and there's factor nodes
and
these
this tree sort of gives us the sort of
structure of observations in some
statistical models so to each
variable node i receive either i don't
receive but there's some unknown scalar
parameter which i'll call theta v
some side information v which i do
observe
factor node i receive an observation
that tells me something about the scalar
parameters or unknown variables
associated with the variable nodes
that
order the factor node okay so in
particular
i receive
some noisy observation of this
linear combination of the variable nodes
in my
boundary
okay and the sort of
objects that enter into this model are
the same ones that enter in the high
dimensional regression model so that
this one-to-one correspondence should be
pretty clear right this prior mu is
going to agree with the one in the high
dimensional regression model and this
kernel p is going to agree with the one
in the high dimensional regression model
and uh okay the ratio of the sort of
there's going to be each factor node is
going to have n neighbors and each
variable node is going to have p
okay so all right that was one the the
model now we're on to step two which is
the
message passing algorithms or the the
algorithms which in this case will be
message passing algorithms
and the message passing algorithms i'm
going to consider at each iteration pass
a scalar quantity from variable to
factor node and from factor to variable
node
the scalar quantity that is passed is as
follows so it's specified by some choice
of functions f and g
the message from the variable to the
factor node is some linear combination
of these sort of
of
messages that were incoming from
the factor nodes to v
and likewise for
the vector
to variable node pass
okay
that's the message passing algorithm
i want to get an estimate of the unknown
parameter at a single variable after t
iterations
i apply
well first i construct this okay maybe
these should have been written in
different order so first i construct
this avt
which is some aggregation of the
messages incoming to that variable node
at iteration t
and then i apply my sort of uh
which aggregates the messages from
each iteration of the algorithm yes
sorry so this is the side information so
yep i guess there's a typo so
[Applause]
i should have put it a zero here or not
a zero
any side information yeah
okay
okay on to step three which is the state
evolution it's the same sort of state
evolution that we have for a p so
we get that the iterates of the message
passing algorithm look like gaussian
observations of the unknown parameters
so in particular the
risk at iteration t
is okay here i've rewritten it and
asymptotically it looks like the same
risk you would get in the scalar model
where now the
sort of scalar model i compare to is
exactly the same as the one i compared
to in the
dimensional regression model so it's
coefficients alpha and these
coefficients and this covariance t
is the same
as i would get by running the amp
algorithm with the same choice of
functions f and g
okay so the bayes risk on the
uh
computation tree
uh
is well i'm not i'm gonna actually
compute sort of a local bayes risk so uh
the thing to observe is that message
passing algorithms are local okay so at
each step they sort of aggregate
information just from their neighborhood
and after t steps the only information
that
i have access to at node v is the
information that occurs out to a radius
in the tree of size 2t
the computation so each variable node
has p
neighbors and each factor node has n
sequence of these models
the same where and the proportional
asymptotics
okay so there's sort of a bayes risk
which is now
not restricting myself to message
passing algorithms i want to come up
with the best statistical estimator
under the constraint that i only observe
information that lives within a radius
2t neighborhood of my
variable node
okay so i can actually i can compute
this posterior exactly using belief
propagation which is you know
which is sort of a message passing
algorithm it's it's not
of the form i showed you because it
tracks more than just scalar quantities
but it's described asymptotically in the
n over p
going to delta proportional asymptotics
by a state evolution so it's summarized
by a few scalar quantities the same
scalar quantities that summarize a and p
and its state evolution is the same as
the state evolution of that bayes a and
p has
okay
so in particular the sort of okay what
you get is that actually
uh
that
the bayes risk is equal to the risk of
bayes amp or said equivalently bayes amp
is
a sort of simpler way of running an
algorithm that achieves the base risk
on the computation tree
great
so the local bayes risk is the risk of
bayes amp
and we already you know something that i
already showed you in the plot for phase
retrieval is that sometimes the risk of
base amp is is worse than
uh
the bayes risk and regression models so
i've already shown you sort of that
there's a difference between the bayes
risk on the
computation tree and on the high
dimensional regression model
uh okay so that's
uh that's the argument so um i've given
you what i promised which is this
storyline
in the two models here's another outline
of it if you'd like so the in the
heinemann on the top i have sort of high
dimensional regression models on the
bottom i have the computation tree
first i reduced first order methods to a
p algorithms
i showed that these have a state
evolution
i showed message passing algorithms on
the computation tree have a state
evolution these are the same state
evolution
and then i was able to
make a compute the base risk uh in both
models
do i have time
uh maybe i'll stop here so yeah so i
well i'll just quickly say so a bit more
about the sparse phase retrieval model
so
uh here's a theorem that you can get
from our results that you know if you
have some uh side information that is
gaussian
then uh
sort of if you're below the spectral
threshold which is the threshold
above which um
uh spectral methods begin to
achieve non-trivial correlation with the
unknown parameter
then uh you have sort of this uh min max
uh
down so that's sort of the
uh quality that any sort of estimation
error that any first order method is
able to achieve is not
you know substantially larger than what
you could have achieved just by looking
at the
site information
hence the side information too much
okay
uh before i finish i should just give a
plug for uh we're going hiking today at
two i'll be leading that hike
um
i'm actually new to berkeley so i don't
actually know if this view occurs on our
hike
but uh hopefully something equally
attractive so i hope to see you there
we'll be meeting outside simon zed too
um
does the result say anything about
initialization so okay what do you uh i
mean i think that'll make sense
so i think uh
so often what you want to do is you want
you know this is
the sort of side information is really
just a crude way of trying to capture
what maybe a special initialization
would achieve but you know yes i think
a more powerful and interesting result
would be to
incorporate the spectral initialization
into
whatever lower bound we produce but
that's sort of
mysterization is not something that is a
first order method so
the only sort of initialization that you
can have is one that is
sort of
uncorrelated with this you can't use
this data matrix x to
construct your
initialization you have to
use noise or something that's
independent of that
i don't know if that answers your
question
but you can use some information which
as you say arises in the site
information
particularly the site information is not
you know uh
correlated with x
how strenuous was the height going to be
what how strenuous is the hike going to
be
i think it's going to be
some
no no no
okay the question was how strenuous is
the height going to be
uh that's going to be a function of how
ambitious the
attendees are going to be i think it's
yeah it's going to be it's
uh there's no
i
however hard people wanna we're gonna go
up to the fire trails behind campus